[Musique]
en application mémoire d'homme c'est une
application qui est téléchargeable sur
tablettes et smartphones que le souvenir
français a mis au point pour
géolocaliser les tombes de morts pour la
france dans les cimetières communaux
on s'est rendu compte que la tombe ça
pouvait vraiment être un lieu de mémoire
une sorte de voyage mémorial de
proximité pour les pour les scolaires du
village pour pour les villageois autour
ma main et qu'en fait la tombe c'est
vraiment le croisement de trois mémoires
c'est à la fois une mémoire familiale
une mémoire locale donc enraciné dans le
territoire et en même temps une mémoire
nationale puisque le mort pour la france
est mort pour la france
au milieu d'eux voilà d'une guerre qui
voit là un pacte et tout le pays
le souvenir français notre mission c'est
vraiment les morts pour la france donc
ceux qui ont eu la mention qui a été
créée en 1915
quand vous téléchargez l'application de
vous êtes dans le cimetière vous vous
retrouvez sur google leur faim et à
l'emplacement de chaque tombes de
soldats morts pour la france devait une
petite cocarde tricolore et vous cliquez
dessus et quand vous cliquez dessus vous
avez la fiche matricule du soldat vous
avez une biographie d'une vingtaine de
lignes plus ou moins dans son fonction
de la densité de sa vie et vous avez
quelques photos donc c'est un vrai un
vrai travail d'historiens qui a été
menée surtout pour les soldats de la
grande guerre
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un travail de dentelle
chaque délégué général d'eau chaque
président du comité local du souvenir
français va avoir le maire et essaye de
le convaincre
en général les maires sont assez
convaincu et je dois dire que les wings
est vraiment un département très
important pour nous parce que sur les 26
cimetière qui sont actuellement sur
l'application yacaman 8 qui sont dans le
département des yvelines